hi there Steve Kaufman here again today
I want to talk about something that I
think is extremely important maybe the
most important thing when it comes to
the techniques of language learning I
talked a lot about the attitudes
required about the amount of time you
need to spend but today I want to talk
about techniques and the reason is
because there was a comment here on a
video that I did a long time ago where I
talked about vocabulary and I the title
of my video was can we learn a hundred
words a day which I believe you can
under certain circumstances and someone
said no because Lida Baker who is an ESL
expert thirty years of experience in
teaching English as a foreign language
says you should concentrate on two or
three no more so let me begin by saying
that I have always felt that the most
important task in language learning is
to acquire words words so that you can
understand what people are saying so
that you can eventually learn to use
these words the task of language
learning is accumulating words and you
need a lot of words I have always said
that the amount of words that you know
passively that you can understand that
is the single most important measurement
of your potential in a language because
the more words you know and understand
even passively the more you can read the
more you can listen the more meaningful
content you can actually expose yourself
to so when it comes to learning words
the idea that you should that leader
suggests that every word you encounter
you should write it on a piece of paper
and on the back again if you're an
English Learner
so therefore in your target language
write up a definition in the back in the
target language write up some synonyms
spend a lot of time on that word and do
two or three a day the problem with that
is that if you do two or three words a
day
that's not very
many words at the end of the year even
if you did 3 ohyea a day that's around a
thousand words problem is a that's not
very many and B you're not gonna
remember them because the learning
process is a process of learning and
forgetting learning and forgetting so
that's problem number one problem number
two is we learn words best in context
and so once you isolate this and create
your own little sentences and synonyms
you're divorced from any context what's
more not only do we learn where it's
better in context when we can associate
it with something we need multiple
contexts because we don't really
understand the meaning of a word and how
it's were used what it means until we've
seen it in many many different contexts
therefore we have to expose ourselves to
a lot of content alright and it's
obvious from my statistics at link that
I learn far more words incidentally
without deliberately trying to learn
them than I do
deliberately trying to learn them what
do I mean by that is that any language
that I have studied for any length of
time and linked my known words total the
number of words that I know which
usually means words that I have not
looked up that I passed by when I was
reading our link is far greater than the
number of words that I saved and then
went about learning because I
encountered them subsequently or
whatever and I moved their status to
known because as we advanced in a
language so we learn the word act and
maybe react and pretty soon we're kind
of getting a sense of this word so when
we see action or activity or activate
all of a sudden we don't have to look
those words up because we or we may look
them up but then very quickly you move
them to known because our power grows
because of that the sort of snowballing
effect of the more words you know
the more words you can guess the more
words them will naturally be added to
your known words total and even in
Chinese as you know more characters you
can then guess the meaning of new
compounds because most words in Chinese
consist of two two characters put
together so you're constantly acquiring
more and more words almost
subconsciously and if your strategy is
to focus on learning two or three words
a day many of which you're gonna forget
you won't learn very many words if I
look at my own experience for example
right now in Arabic so I should say too
that the number of words you can learn
per day is going to depend on how close
the language is to a language you
already know so if you're a speaker of a
Romance language you know if you learn
another Romance language you're gonna
learn words very very quickly
in two months I had a vocabulary in
Romanian of 20,000 words okay however
with Greek where there are far fewer
words that you know I recognize from
other languages I think I was learning
about 50 words a day and I was picking
up speed because again the more words I
know the more likely that I'm going to
encounter different forms of that word
and therefore I'm not gonna have to save
it and so my my vocabulary learning
starts to pick up speed but I was
running at about fifty words a day
now with Arabic I checked my statistics
I'm over 3,000 words three thousand two
hundred words or so I've been out of
about a hundred and fifty days so that's
about twenty a day but I know that I'm
gonna pick up speed in my Arabic so 20
words a day is is at a low point because
I'm struggling with an unfamiliar script
because I'm still trying to get a
toehold on the language because I don't
have many or if any or a very very few
identifiable words from other languages
but that's still 20 a day it's not two
or three a day because I know from
experience that to be comfortable in a
language I need 20,000 30,000 40,000
50,000 words granted it's the way we
count the middle
where we consider every form of the word
as a different word so it's not
something that I can go brag about that
I know so many words and I certainly
can't use all those words but it is a
bit of a measurement it's a milestone
it's it's also an incentive I want to
push that number up as as much as I can
because I know that if I start to reach
like right now I'm an hour Arabic I'm at
3,000 words I said I'm gonna start
speaking I have in fact had four
conversations with an Arabic tutor at
itok II and so 3,000 words had it to me
is normally much earlier than I'd like
to start speaking at I think in checked
our waited till I had five or six
thousand words it doesn't matter but I
know that to be comfortable in Arabic
I'm gonna need 20,000 words
if I read a newspaper article in Arabic
I'm looking up two-thirds of the words
so I'm nowhere near I have a sense for
the language I have some common
vocabulary but in order for me to be
where I want to be I can't be learning
at one or two or three words a day
adding into that the fact that I'm gonna
forget most of them this is the other
thing it's elusive you think you've
learned something you think you've
learned a word you know if you aren't
constantly reading and listening and
encountering that word in many different
situations you're gonna lose it and so
therefore the strategy has to be to not
worry too much about learning words I
don't spend a lot of time reviewing
words I review them after a lesson once
but I don't go through my long list of
saved words and then some kind of a you
know an effort to try and nail down
words in isolation from the the lesson I
review words immediately after a lesson
just to give me a bit of a chance or I
sometimes go back to a lesson that I've
read five six seven times and rather
than reading through the whole lesson I
just go through on link those words and
phrases that continue to give me trouble
but always connected to that context and
then I listen to the lesson so it's
always context can
so e-learning vocabulary to me is the
most important task you need lots of
words you need words in order to speak
to people otherwise you can't understand
what they're saying back to you and the
native speaker has a lot of words so you
have to at least understand those words
even if you use a smaller subset of
those words that you understand
passively so focus on learning words
learn the words through massive
listening and reading don't spend your
time as Lida Baker's suggests cutting
out making little cards and writing you
know how much time does that take like I
don't have if I had 810 hours a day I
might do what she suggested but I have
an hour or two a day the bulk of it is
simply listening I have to have a
strategy that enables me to learn words
naturally incidentally while doing those
tasks that I find enjoyable and that are
easy for me to do and I think her
strategy is not that and I will leave a
link to that article and I thank the
person who raised the comment or the
question to that YouTube video of mine
so thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]